I'm getting to a point where I can really
take a step back and evaluate all the things about myself
that I don't like.
I can play victim.
No cats will ever cuddle with me because I'm disgusting!
I can be dishonest when I'm afraid of consequences.
Did you eat the last slice of pizza?
What?  No!  Congress did.
And if we're being real here, I can be a bitch.
Dude, are you sure you're not mad?
*intense music*
Yeah.
I'm sure.
And I'm not like that all the time.
Like don't get me wrong.  I have good qualities.  I'm generous.
I got you another cat!  Yay!
I'm thoughtful.
I thought about you a lot today.  A lot.  Naked.
I'm well intentioned.
I bought you your favorite sandwich but then I ate it .
But out of all the qualities I have,
the one thing that I absolutely want to change
is that I'm mean to the people that I love.
And I don't know why!  You know?  It makes no sense at all.
Because you want to treat the people that you love
the best because you love them.
Right?  It's like what's up with that?
Is it because they're always around and you think
they're always going to be around so you kind of
take them for granted.
Either way, I really hate that I act like this.
Hey, Anna?
What?!
I was just wondering--
I'm working!
I know, I just need--
I am working.  Don't you see that I am working?
All right then..
Love you!
And the only thing I can attribute it to
and I'm sorry to call this out on the internet
but I think I learned it from my dad.
And he's not like this anymore but when I was a kid he was so mean!
Hey dad?
What!?
I was just wondering if--
I'm working!
Yeah, I know but--
I'm working.  Don't you see that I am working?
Ok.  I'll ask you later..
Love you sweetie!
So I was talking to my therapist about it and he said:
Being self-aware is the first step toward taking action.
Now that you are aware of the problem, what you can do
is to start conditioning yourself to stop doing it.
What happens is, as you catch yourself,
that time between your reaction and when you realize what you've done wrong
gets shorter and shorter and shorter
until you're catching yourself before you can even react.
At that point, it's just about establishing
a new healthy positive behavior.
So I'm trying to remedy that.
Wish me luck.
I'm really excited to announce that I have two short films coming out this Summer.
One is called "Loose Ends."  It's a thriller.
It's 23 minutes long so it's the longest thing I've ever done.
And it's found-footage style.  It's about two best friends
who are recent college grads.
And chaos ensues!
And the second one is "Supers & Associates."
It's a comedy.  I've been pitching it as The Office meets Brooklyn 99 but with super heroes.
And that one is about 13 minutes now.
So I'm really excited because I feel like I've come really far as a filmmaker.
And I think these 2 short films are by far some of the best things I've done to date.
Oh!  And I want to say thank you to Audible for sponsoring today's episode!
Someone asked me to do a Mickey Mouse voice, so here we go:
Hoh!  I really want to say thank you to Audible.com for sponsoring today's episode.
Haha!
You can go to Audible.com/Anna for a free audiobook of your choice!
They have over 150,000 titles to choose from!  Haha so many!
Right now, I'm listening to "The Power of Habit" because I really want to change those habits of mine.
Haha!
You can get that or another free audiobook of your choice
over at Audible.com/Anna.  That is Audible.com/Anna
Haha!
Thanks Audible.  I really appreciate being able to listen to you while I'm driving
in that Los Angeles traffic.  Haha!
I'm Anna Akana.  I will see you next Monday.  Stay awesome Gotham.